my name is Peggy Mason I am a professor
of Neurobiology at the University of
Chicago and I'm really excited to share
with you the results of a collaboration
with jean de sette and in bulb art hall
where we looked at empathy and helping
behavior in rats we've known for some
time that rats show the simplest form of
empathy emotional contagion such as one
baby cries all the babies cry we wanted
to see if rats would go beyond emotional
contagion to actively help another rat
in distress this is really asking quite
a bit of a rat as act of helping
requires that the helper rat down
regulate the fear he is experiencing
through emotional contagion in other
words the helper has to suppress his
natural response of frozen immobility
and actually moved to help the other rat
so we put a free rat the rat with the
black dot on his head into an arena and
in the center is his cage mate trapped
in a plexiglass restrainer the door to
the restrainer can only be open from the
outside by the free rat here you're
seeing the first five minutes sped up on
the first day of testing even though it
takes quite a bit of rat courage to
venture into the scary arena center the
free rat persists in moving to the
center and trying to figure this
restrainer thing out so he can help his
cage mate so now in this clip the rats
have been in this paradigm several times
this is the fifth day of testing and
we're viewing the session in real time
but after 25 minutes have elapsed what
you see is that the free rat is very
focused on the door you will see him
open the door for the first time in a
moment what I want you to notice is that
the free rat freezes he freezes because
the door falls over and since it's the
first time he's opened the door he's
surprised and he startles by freezing at
the sound of the falling door there he
goes now after a brief exploration of
the strange land of the restrainer the
liberated rat runs around exploring the
arena
wherever the liberated rat goes the free
rat follows jumping on and licking him
for about five to ten minutes this
apparent celebration continues with the
free right very active
and always in close proximity to his
liberated cage mate
here's day 12 in real time from the very
start of the stash of the session the
free rat is placed in the arena and
after briefly checking that this is the
same gig as every previous day he
promptly opens the door but he no longer
freezes when the door falls over and his
reaction to liberating the trap rat is
quite muted suggesting that the free
ride is not surprised by the results of
his actions in another experiment that
we don't show you here we put two
restrainer in the arena one with the
trap cage mate one with five chocolate
chips remarkably the free rat opened
both restraints and in no consistent
order and to our shock the free right
shared the chocolates with the liberated
rat this told us that helping a cage
mate is on a par with chocolate a truly
palatable and favourite rat snack we are
confident that it is the trap rat that
elicits door opening as the rats do not
open the restrainer when the restrainer
is it either empty or contains a toy rat
moreover even when we prevented the free
rat access to the liberated rat he
opened the door showing that he did not
simply want to play with his cage mate
all of this tells us that acting on
empathic feelings to help another in
need is a biological and in fact a
neurobiological mandate it's in our
brain
you